okay for those joining this livestream
we are talking about some language
completeness and consistency it's used
for often language for those of you who
are just in a meeting about image and
audio functions this is a bunch of
different kinds of things alright let's
get started okay first up we have norm
happening with norm okay Oh real norms
right I thought we just had a function
that did what is the function that does
we don't know but we have real ABS is
for vectors it's not right now real ABS
is for numbers it will be it will less
it well thread over the list I'm pretty
sure so what does it do for what is real
ABS do if I say I what is it it will
just return none evaluated okay what is
it for again that's really for the case
of symbolic X and you want it to be
right it's so when you differentiate
real ABS of X with respect to X you get
by the way I'm sorry this is the era
could somebody could somebody yeah this
needs to be reported to Roger like
immediately because the machines that
I'm about to take on a trip in a couple
of hours don't have this problem like a
pilot update problem
oh for goodness sake well whatever okay
right so if you put in real ABS of X and
then you differentiate that with respect
to X you would get a piecewise constant
I see okay so this is a differentiation
okay so what you're saying for norm what
is the point for normal
okay so right so the point is right so
and it's not necessarily just norm so we
have right so right now if you do norm
of X Y you get right you'll get absolute
value of x squared plus absolute value
of y squared and maybe you want to just
get out x squared plus y squared
maybe you mean the square root of x
squared plus y squared yes right so you
mean and so for example if I
differentiate that with respect to X I
get that right and arguably so what if I
want to get real ABS here so make sense
realize is not necessary because it
could just be x squared right right well
so that is that that is one of the
issues because but this norm that makes
sense but if I say how do I get how do I
get the what does that do yeah okay so
that does that so you do want real apps
in that case indeed right
so and I can get crazy things like that
- great now when do you not want real
abs in the case in for norm when the
norm is an even integer well okay well
so there's there's a question its if P
if P is irrational with an even
numerator you can avoid the relapse
right now one of the issues is and I
think there might be a typo there that
that's a one rather than an I in in so
under the last last bullet point there's
a point it's right there's an example
there norm of 1 comma a new option goes
to true right and there's a question of
so suppose you want the real you know
the this this new option and you and you
evaluate norm of you know 1 comma I do
you want something that returns
unevaluated or do you want 0 yeah I
understand you my claim is that if you
do that then then it's no longer a norm
normally wants to stop commute
themselves okay
all right so the question is there are
two questions what whether to get real
abs like an in this case here we might
want real ABS of X cubed
second in the case of even powers even
numerator powers do we want to get rid
of the ABS in altogether and I'm making
sense
right if we if we just stick in real
labs everywhere then you know there I
don't think there's much of a question
why I mean there's a little question of
do we return just the answer with ABS
replaced by real ABS even though there's
an I in there which we know doesn't make
any sense or well I'm talking about that
complicated case I'm just talking about
the simple case okay so in the case of
numbers okay what are the cases
okay the cases are one numbers sub case
real numbers so so if all the numbers in
it are real numbers then none of this
matters
okay so all irrelevant yep okay so next
case is symbolic yep right and there
the main point is you know beauty of
expressions so to speak yep that's
differentiable let's say that correct
right then we can now that we have real
ABS we can separate those right because
we can get real ABS which will give us a
French ability even if at least in some
case even if in the default case which
is you know the even you know the two
norm it's you know not as beautiful as
it could be yes I understand it will get
the right answer correct because real
ABS prime is equal to zero one it's it's
it's plus or minus 1 depending on
whether X is positive or negative
it's the piecewise yeah okay fine it
turns into piecewise okay all right so I
get it this somewhat bizarre case of
complex
numbers okay so I mean to me you know it
almost seems like the thing should be
called ABS function arrow ABS identity
or real ABS I mean that's kind of the
that's kind of being very direct but
it's not only UPS its conjugated us to
try frac for example projection of list
X Y comma list UV so we were hoping to
have a single solution that would
eliminate all those conjugate well but
you do agree that there are two cases
here the case of identity or the case of
real labs what would this do in the real
ABS case is there an analog of real ABS
here in this case no because projection
is is unique to the two norm because
only in the two norm cases at an inner
product space okay
now look at the argument structure I
mean so what you want is something I
mean in other functions we have say
comma reals for example that isn't
distinguishing between the real abs and
the and the nothing case but that will
be the case that we would just select
what you're talking about here right you
could have said you could have well as
well have said here norm of you know
list comma 2 comma reals that would have
been the analog of what we would do in
the case of let's say solve right now
adding this optional argument doesn't
work so nicely for normalize because
normalised takes a function in the
second argument rather than a number so
this is why we were thinking it should
be an option boy but if it's an option
here surely it should also be an option
and solve and so on and because in let's
say and reduce right right which is the
domain right right which is slightly
different because right there it's
actually changing even if right even if
they're sort of you know even for
numeric things right because if you want
to solve x squared equals minus one over
the reals it's going to tell you there's
no solution so why isn't I mean this it
so happens that this thing can barrel
ahead and get to an answer in all cases
in the case of norm right I don't see
that there's a big difference there I
don't see how we can consistently not
use well I guess the other I mean the
other disadvantage for this to being an
optional argument rather than an option
right this that you'll need to put in
the two in order to get the real so I
agree which is not beautiful but that's
that's it's actually not I've argued
before when you had a branch where you
put them in a list they since since
number P is completely distinguishable
from a domain you could actually just
maybe not document but allow the syntax
norm of lists comma reals and it's
unambiguous exact true for all of these
functions like normalized for example I
think it's probably fairly unambiguous
Oh as I'm not so sure but norm clearly
it's unambiguous okay what this would do
is it would drop the conjugates it would
drop the abscess and there will be no
way to get a relapse there because you
just don't care about the relapse is
that true you do care about the relapse
for this case right so it would drop it
could potentially drop the real ABS in
the case where right you have an even in
this case what it would do is it would
replace those ABS is by relapses right
and it would return presumably unev al
you aided or with a ridiculous sort of
relapse expression if you gave it one
comma I your choice I don't have an
opinion about that one I think I know
valuated would be better okay listen my
take is are there any other functions
implicated other than Norman normalized
at this time potentially something like
in standardized try standardized of ABC
euclidean distance what would you like
to do with Euclidean distance well it
would need to be an optional an option
or an optional third argument the right
so he had norm normalize there's also
orthogonalize that's horrible off for
presumably the projection as well yeah
yeah the statistics there's also
variance
right and from right and from projection
you also get orthogonalize right
whatever we do here we should also
support in in reduce okay so if we have
an option here you know we have an
assumptions option already for many
things but it requires explicitly laying
out what you want to you know a is an
element of reals and things like this
right right if the one advantage I see
if say an assumed reals option is that
we could have we could actually have a
dollar assume reals right that was false
and that that would be the default check
for the option and then somebody really
wanted to work in reals I could just set
that and yeah but it's not gonna work
and you know we have a thousand
functions well that doesn't work yes I
know
I know that's just silly if I might say
so I mean you know it's it's promising
something we can't deliver personally
that ignore assumptions right and yet we
still document and use assumptions a lot
so why don't these functions have
assumptions like norm I guess
I mean an interesting possibility would
be to say that assumptions could just
say reals in other words to allow the
possibility to use to just say
assumptions are reals up till now
assumptions has always been the boolean
valued expressions or valid that's quite
well that's quite a break what it would
mean and it's a convenient form of
assumptions to start talking about
changing assumptions and we should have
an atom here and he's currently away
yeah worried about propagating
assumption too many places because right
now the way to do this is more like
assuming and you put expressions inside
but if it's that many functions that
have some sense of chance no I
understand that
but I'm suggesting that these that
there's not a good excuse for why norm
doesn't have an assumptions option right
but I don't think I mean possibly but I
don't think if norm takes an assumption
option it should be treated the same as
any other place yeah and I don't know
that that's cut to the case of what we
can do right now I think these third
argument cases are ok we should
inventory all of them to make sure there
are no horrible problems I think that's
something we can support I think adding
an option that we will need to back
propagate in to solve and reduce and so
on is iffy right now but I think we
should talk to Adam and those guys about
whether they're prepared to have such an
option I think it is worth considering
assumptions like generalizing that I
think that
but I think it's not inconsistent I
don't think there's a problem because
what we will be doing with reduce is
saying you can have the reals domain
argument or you can have the assumptions
or you can have whatever this assuming
option is well well the solving reduced
with a with produce or solve over the
reals is not the same thing as so you
know the same function assuming all the
variables are real valued yeah okay I
understand
yes I understand right which is you know
sort of why this case is a little bit
different is we're sort of making we're
allowing sort of intermediate things and
we're just sort of stating let's assume
that these guys are you know things
which aren't obviously complex are
assumed to be real by the way I assume
that if I had a you know obviously if I
say norm F of whatever it will likewise
it will assume that every symbolic
expression that appears is real right so
if I were to say norm of you know f of X
G of Y right it's going to assume that
that's just F of x squared plus G of Y
squared right so it's assuming that
every element of the vector is real yes
it pretty much has to do that no I
understand but that's different from
where as reduce might if reduce was done
yeah but the assumptions is different in
that if you had an assumption on X and
you knew something about F then it could
determine that F was should be real and
after cording Lee
I just don't think we can have an option
here because it's gonna promise
something it absolutely can't deliver in
other parts of the system right so right
so I mean this is the me abusing a
assumption or sorry abusing the name of
the option but sort of and maybe we can
come up with a better name but sort of
one of the suggested option names at the
top was conjugated goes to true or false
certainly in right this handles the two
norm and standardized and projection and
all those guys what it doesn't handle is
you know so the one normally obscure and
I also worry that that very name is
going to be needed in chemistry and all
kinds of weird stuff okay right fine so
we need to come up with a better name
but possibly you know a name that was
sort of more that but I think the way
people will think about this is I just
want to assume that everything is real I
mean I do think that's what people want
to do okay what do we what is the
objection right now to adding like the
third argument to normal well in a lot
of places it's you know it doesn't make
any sense
right and then normalize it doesn't make
sense unless the second argument is
explicitly a number which I don't know
if that's currently supported but that's
going what's going to be one of our
enhancements as we were working on this
that you can put a number in the second
that means norm with that number right
but this doesn't help your argument
because if it doesn't make sense
with an arbitrary F there doesn't make
sense with an arbitrary F there either
but up options don't have to make sense
for every possible thing there are that
don't affect all possible combinations
of arguments I understand well the same
is true of some arguments he says not
being able to think of an immediate
example so for normal eyes you could
just use F is you know function of norm
of swap comma 2 comma reals that's
really obscure which is obscure right I
mean I would say the amount of use of
normalized versus the amount of use of
norm is a small percentage right then I
guess I suppose I would worry a bit
about of having a domain like argument
because we might want actual domains
there but maybe maybe that's okay maybe
well right I mean if you have a matrix
and you know you want its norm in you
know this matrix group is supposed to
that matrix group I mean this is norm
case yes in the norm well norm or
normalize that's not something I think
that extends as naturally to things like
projection or whatnot right because
projection really you have to be an
inner product space and so listen let's
get a list of all functions that care
about this two things okay
all functions that care about this right
now and all functions like reduce that
might in the future care about an option
that says assume everything is real
okay I mean I think there are even
plenty of other functions like like a
famous you know X to the power one-third
assume everything is real what does it
mean you know that's our cube roots
thing and so on
but let's start off in my my tentative
conclusion is that we should have
another argument for norm okay okay
should we go into the next su yep okay
is this a can of worms
it's necessary it looks yeah the worms
are very um I won't say the worms are
edible particularly slimy okay good
okay so I think that somebody here is
that Rob needs some changes in total for
his optimization project and in the
process he's fixing a bunch of ugly
things in total so let me ask a couple
questions so in what what aspects of
total is stupid
oh that's absolutely stupid that is
absolutely stupid that's absolutely
stupid and and shouldn't be that way I
have now total of two pi equals two plus
PI that makes sense to me right so if
you look at the if you have a prototype
build and you open the future eyes if
you open the source notebook you'll see
tentative notes and and some examples
we've got a bunch of background noise if
we could try and cut that on a bit great
right and so we have this pre-existing
option that hasn't been documented in
which you want it to be renamed and this
is a case where we sort of the new name
doesn't make sense so that's sort of the
issue it's really the name of this
option and how exactly we want to
proceed but this this note has to be
removed right
right it's that will be removed once you
know this is murder instant so that's an
that's is ultimately an incompatible
change but one that I cannot imagine
anybody has relied on because it's so
bizarre right basically I made the
change in the sources and and we only
found a few a couple a couple of test
failures in the whole test suite and the
example he uses this is just absolutely
ridiculous and stupid is it from the
wild example or is it a made-up example
it's it basically somebody gets the
total derivative order by by doing total
of derivative of blah blah blah which is
yeah it's just a made-up example okay
have we looked at okay have we looked at
demonstrations and things like that okay
and there will be a way to recover that
old behavior using this allowed heads
option okay elements inside of lists
boss
okay automatic inherited for that one
what was the loud heads do in other
cases so it's not documented I don't
think it can't get gift it works I think
a her a Q and read depth and and kind of
sort of in transpose but not really okay
doesn't it I think they're an effective
allowed heads for things like the simple
location simplify function doesn't that
have some kind of allowed forms type
thing I don't think so I mean it has you
know you can transformation functions
right you can something has this
excluded forms okay different we got a
bunch of background noise could we
please try to cut it out
you
I think that this should be automatic
and this case should be inherited
you
am i making sense
everybody's on mute so only the person
was walking around who needed to be on
mute yeah inherited inherited is fine
but I think you know automatic then
maybe should be the the default which is
list and social I just said I thought
you were pointing to the list and saying
that should be automatic sorry
oh well how do you get the default with
with the current thing well you have to
tell you I mean it just works or you you
should make the default case should be
automatic I agree that list could be I
somewhat reluctantly agree that list
could be less sparser a structured array
okay what about data set hey no I don't
think total works with data set except
as a normal expression that's that's a
completely different project well no
it's not a completely different project
a data set it's effectively a list of
associations at cetera et cetera
oh well then if it works with
Association or work with data sets I
don't know you got to try it okay what
we got to figure out how to adjust this
or the oh because it's really kind of
it's like if they just hit bring them
okay fine so what does it do what does
it treat isn't allowed head well I think
it's just going inside and working as
able to work with associations and lists
okay right right but only if the data
said this at the topmost level because
it's implemented via not value like
everything else and data set
okay so the name yes so this is the
point we wanted to discuss oh you mean
the other thing was uncontroversial and
this is the only part it's controversial
well you you at one point we talked
about documenting aloud heads possibly
once with you know once we've actually
cleaned up some of the implementation
but you didn't like allowed heads and
insisted it should be renamed array
allowed heads accepting that name
doesn't work in this case so it's only
controversial if you still object to
allowed heads why did i hook before
because you because I was saying doesn't
work on non arrays anyway because I
think the previous uses we were thinking
of we're all related to a race liking
right the previous uses really were
array related because they were depth
they were transpose and transpose
absolutely positive you know depth you
can maybe argue whether or not it has to
be array but transpose it absolutely
positively has to be an array array
that's okay so the question is whether
we array depth could have other random
heads lying around that are not arrayed
I think it's alright I mean I is there a
problem is there an obvious problem with
that no I much favored using allowed
heads because it it's more usable in
other functions like toga yeah
okay but so a raid app I see a loud
heads here with inherited would take the
top-level thing and enforce that and say
how many levels down it is well yeah
okay which is it gonna be hit okay
sounds okay to me
a loud heads is fine so we go into the
next item yes just to confirm so then
the basic case of list only
that's called Lee story sit call
automatic no that should be cooled list
that's this automatic is list or
Association this list of lists things or
associations I see yeah so yes an
automatic I mean they suppose the
question I mean should automatic mean
the same thing and should that be the
default in all heads and should it be
all functions yes in all functions I
don't know has to be the same in all
functions yeah okay automatic could mean
different things for different functions
Yeah right fine okay okay so this is
working yes so we have these three
pretty functions ready for you to see
with nice rough pages and they no matrix
does work enough for hiring tensors true
true or not true I don't think that's
true this is matrices
I see so if I want to make a diagonal
tensor by the way Rob you are implicated
in this weird background noise
now he's gone um okay so how do I make a
diagonal tensor using the sparse array
construct using structured array or what
is the approach
and it doesn't make any sense to have
diagonal cue work on a diagonal tensor I
mean right so yes and of course I mean
one of the issues is that sort of right
if the right these these arguments would
need to be changed right in the second
it's still feet rised so I was just
trying you know matrix what is lower
triangle how do I get there's lower
triangular triangular eyes
yes obably gosh it's been that for ages
yeah right so I mean right and one of
the issues is that the concept of the
diagonal right it's no longer the second
argument will no longer be a number
it'll be a list of rank minus one things
what are you talking about which for
diagonal matrix and diagonal matrix Q if
you the second argument which specifies
which diagonal right that's no longer a
number that's list of rank minus one
numbers I guess I'm basically in short
I'm arguing that these should all be
matrix specific and if we want a
generalized function we can have I don't
think it's worth having the generalized
function is thank you I think by the
time you're doing this with the tensor
that has a you know a single stripe
through it somewhere that you'll want to
do that with sparse array I agree with
that Stephen I think that's right why
doesn't this refer to structure array
here or spa
sorry because it hasn't been touched
since version 7 well I guess that
explains structured array don't think
that explains sparse array but it
probably should we can add that or you
can add it now no all right if you want
to look at the future ice trough pages
for these three functions
yep
arguably one should have the the Q
version of this as well you know is an N
by n diagonal matrix blah blah blah
maybe right the right the point of that
one is you can specify fewer than n
elements or or well that also truncate
no it it says pads right so the point is
that that I assume that it would
truncate if they I assume that n is the
winning thing that's true you should
check it ya know and should be the
winning thing but the more important
more interesting case of that is the
second to last note or it's you can
create you can create a rectangular
matrix okay so I would argue that
diagonal matrix Q should have the
complimentary set of arguments but but
Stephen that doesn't make sense because
if you if you truncate or pad it's still
diagonal I think I agree with Rob so
this would look like check only a subset
of the matrix for example if and it's a
smaller than the dimensions of the
matrix and that's something we don't do
any I was thinking but okay I was
thinking it was a double test of test
both for diagonal acetate so to speak
and for size but you're telling me that
that's some we really don't have tests
for size the only the only thing that
implies size and test is square matrix Q
okay fine I believe and typically you
can do you can do size dimensions Baba
okay
fine okay let me see yeah okay
looks okay yeah these look fine to me
I mean look let's gel just look at one
of these now it's kind of annoying that
we have to have a whole function just
for this this functionality but I guess
it's you know I think it's less obscure
than having some kind of it's like
rotate left rotate right it's kind of
annoying we have to have two functions
but otherwise you'd never remember which
one was which
right and they're certainly sufficiently
discussed concepts that they're worth
having yes okay okay all right let's
have a quick look at information I'm
we're over time here inspect oh boy
token information it's like it's a token
right so if if you if you insist that
this new function be called
information stealing the old information
then we need a name for that old
function and my suggestion is token
information because it can take either a
symbol or an operator but so I mean
there's a very I suppose we can argue
about those specifics but they're sort
of one sort of general point here which
is you know this is sort of the extent
of the functionality that's been
implemented and we can you know do some
graphic design but sort of in terms of
something you know a radical redesign of
the function itself of the functionality
I don't think you know that's that's not
in the cards for 12 given the other
things that Nick needs to work on
yeah and I think this is perfectly nice
what you have here okay
this is perfectly useful and why is it
that you want to break off the token
case well no my point is that
information is currently a function so
if that's not a prototype build and you
type in information of plot or
information of the string Plus you will
get if it is a prototype build you're
saying no if it's not I want to it comes
in a perfect information about the
symbol yeah wow that does that I don't
know what happens if you give it the
string plus okay so meanwhile that is in
comparison to that was some beautiful
output so what is the argument here so
my point is that that needs to exist
since it has existed since version 1
well let's look at this case Oh lawful
raffle give it a string containing plus
you mean the symbol character plus yes
oh yeah so that's so that actually works
that's nice yeah well then because we
didn't want the argument there the new
function to be held the idea was you can
use the string form to reference
function names or variable names without
having to hold wrapper holding around
them yes so Nick is saying if in your
end of 12 there you change that to the
string xx it should give you something
I'm not filled about the values
structure there I think it should be
more elegant that yeah there's a there's
a basic clean up pass for the formatting
code we so for system symbols and and
things to find in packets we don't show
the down values in those forms but
exactly how we want to nicely typeset
down values and up values for
user-defined functions isn't super well
mapped out hey there's a comment on the
live stream that's interesting which is
how come diagonal matrix Q doesn't take
a second argument which is like this
test argument here
what does it it is not and it's not
clear what sort of tests you might want
there well what it does take is the
second argument is the position of the
diagonal right I think we have discussed
this in the past the problem is that we
have now very many X matrix q functions
and none of them takes a test so the
idea was that each of these new
functions would take would test for some
property of the matrix and the test
would be reduced to matrix Q itself I
could also argue that if you wanted to
do the test presumably on the diagonal
elements you could do you know test of
diagonal or vector q of diagonal matrix
comma test and actually I think
furthermore it would be ambiguous
whether you're the test was being
applied to the diagonal elements or the
non diagonal elements I mean if we could
make it clearer but I would I would have
to read the documentation every time I
used to remember which was which all
right that's a reasonable argument I
agree that's a reasonable argument okay
anyway useful Cohen though um okay back
to this
I like the name information so this will
not have been used programmatically I
mean it will have been used well every
time you do question mark which we could
change to using this one here now
why not because because question mark
first of all needs to work nicely in the
in the standalone kernel and now we got
multiple different moving parts here
okay question mark does not have to map
to information of blah right so for
example in external if you do question
mark of plot it still refers to the old
function which we temporarily an
external renamed symbol information
which is a name e type doesn't love
because it doesn't always refer to a
symbol and that's sort of where token
information came out of what does it
refer to other than a symbol operators
that's wild it's been there for as far
back as I can run kernels we can try to
I finally go to version 1 running on the
Mac I see 30 it will use up probably 2
megabytes of memory trying to figure
that out okay
okay so there's nothing fun
dimensionality in external other than
maybe some graphic design of those gray
boxes seems perfectly nice I think uses
the name information so what we are
missing is the explicit name of what
question mark turns into or possibly an
alternate name for information
information for this I think I mean I
inspect I don't buy at all just isn't
the right thing I mean it's you know
it's just information on the thing I do
not buy at all you're you're asking for
properties of this blah because we're
not using inspect for anything
I mean inspect is much more like a
debugger type thing it you know this is
when we say information of an entity and
things like that it's really not
inspecting the entity inspecting the
entity will be looking inside at the
canonical forms and so on whereas this
is really information about the entity I
don't think this says anything was
entities and the current version does
okay I guess I was remembering some old
freshmen which didn't so let's let's go
back and look at the question mark case
okay so you're saying we need a
programmatic way we need a full form for
question mark plot I mean isn't question
mark plot a special input form doesn't
even have a full form no so you mean it
has two parts it goes through the loop
it has to parse okay so if I if I say
something like this that may not work in
the note that yeah that doesn't work in
a notebook because of why would argue a
a front-end bug I think but it would
work in a standalone kernel a little bit
but originally in version wha
question mark was a special input form
that question mark at the beginning of a
line like exclam exclam at the beginning
of the line was a shell escape question
mark at the beginning of the line was a
help escape so to speak that was the
original intention mm-hmm eyes and
typing guys
well that hasn't been true in two
decades really really okay so if I go to
a standalone kernel here mm-hmm
could we type in please type in don't
type
you
great
you
okay so question mark plot hardly
beautiful but functional I guess
actually that's more beautiful than I
rather remember it
how does it do the supplies
the subscripts like that
[Music]
and the third line doesn't look good the
the subscript eyes are shifted over too
far well there is a bug dots aren't
misplaced there's also a known bug where
it counts when it's doing the alignment
it's counting the number of bites rather
than the number of characters so if
those dot dots are you know you know two
or three bites then that'll be the
spacing will be off this is coming out
as a side effect right this is a mess I
mean yeah this is from the time of
floppy discs could we please cut out the
typing could you please put yourself on
mute if you are typing
you
you
you
could we call the old symbol the castle
information look yes it's possible but
but but it doesn't even have to be in
the system context does it it's never
going to be seen people are not going to
use it as a um yeah Sandra on the live
stream is suggesting info which we did
think about before but I like
information I think it's I think the
problem that we have is that we've we
have not well maintained this okay let's
look at this again for a minute what
what it is it's really doing is this a
side effect here anybody know the answer
to that basically printing it if that's
what you're asking
okay and that is a syntax error yes
although you believe it shouldn't be
yeah it's it's open to debate
but yeah it's really a relatively minor
point that nobody how would you feel and
to me this would make a lot of sense if
question mark at the beginning of a line
did something more like this in other
words because that's equals at the
beginning of a line and now we're off in
a different world and we are able to
just you know happily process things in
a different way and to me putting a
question mark at the beginning of a line
well I mean changing the graphic design
is fine that doesn't change the fact
that it you know needs to parse to
something in order of this doesn't this
doesn't I mean this parse is to wolf now
for day you know what now for that's
true well that's still parsing to
something right there fine fine I mean
this could parse which then evaluates
yeah just let's evaluate is this going
through the evaluation yes look your
ends are being incremented boy that's
wrong see here if I do this wow
the ends are being incremented there too
but that's the kind of thing that I
thought question mark was doing here
know what I'm saying
right and it's not not anymore
I wonder what that was changed more than
20 years ago you said right my guess
would be version 3 when you know it had
you know he sent over math link from the
front end to the kernel and in BA in
boxy form but I could be wrong
all right what does it say in the
documentation page for information
you
prints information about a symbol
the input escape
oh boy do you see that this is a
different no no but first what says
input escape but second of all it's
saying it's the input escape question
mark question mark which raises the
question what is a single question mark
it's it's it's information with the
option long form equals short false or
so that this is really ancient there's
an even document long form up here which
is another bug all right okay listen
listen
I think information should be changed to
its modern form it should remove the
whole dole attribute I think Roman
noticed by the way when we added at the
prototype he sent an email complaining
about the fact that information was
untold all anymore so at least one
person noticed that but what about the
info I don't like it I just don't like
it
no we went through this last time we
went through this last time we spent
like half an hour last time looking at
the different possible words and
information is the right word
you know info is kind of like a possible
hacker hack word which I don't
particularly like does anybody
particularly like info here would you
like to touch justified if I need
confusing if we keep information oh it's
terribly confusing all right so okay
all right why do you want to keep this
form of information I mean getting the
print out in a terminal is easy but we
can easily turn this thing to not to
print out in some more civilized way and
we need that by the way because these
are other information things we need a
standardized way to print these summary
blobs in on the terminal because it's
something I use all the time and I think
people what will you use question mark
whatever yes in the terminal front end
in the end and notebooks okay fine I'm
not saying look in question mark I'm
saying okay we've got two issues one
this looks different from this okay
that's partly a graphic design issue I
don't know you know I think somewhere
between these two is probably the
perfect form of that summary blob by
making sense
it's fold also I can do it on I can
easily do it on symbols without knowing
whether or not they have own values
that's a different objection you're
using information to do that right
what do you mean using information to do
that no using the function information
with an evaluation symbol or are you
using question mark
either way it's fold oh no no no what
are you actually using in practice
question mark question okay fine all
right now notice that we could easily
make question mark deal with the an
evaluator this - for example if question
marks simply turn that into a string it
would immediately deal with the unev
alleyways you this year
yes it will also deal with the /su
so would the idea be to have I was
wondering if we have some sort of option
for legacy form that if you really want
the old version it's a question of
formatting we changed the formatting a
few years ago and there wasn't a big
outcry but I'm telling you we need a
compromise between these two kinds of
formatting right and I guess regardless
of the the formatting functionality
there is a use case that question mark
gets used for which is looking for
wildcard patterns and symbol names so
plot asterisks to get okay it's a
magnificent okay I mean by the way yes
that's fine the thing you guys are
missing is the mapping from the question
mark form to information does not have
to be you know just take this the
argument and stick it in the first
argument of information right if there
is a wild-card form there then by all
means we can turn into something which
can successfully wildcard things that's
useful yes sir I guess the the thought I
was having that I didn't articulate well
is if we don't have a good name for what
the old form is is there a case to be
made that information can be called with
an option that says give me the old
version of information but I mean
information would also be useful to
probably support wildcard strings mm-hmm
why not whatever question mark does you
know I don't see why we shouldn't allow
information to do the same thing for a
wild-card string
am I making sense so that this would be
equivalent to information a piece store
mm-hmm I don't think there's a problem
with this I think this is just gonna
work I think the the mapping is question
mark turns into
information of the string whatever comes
after the question mark the single
question mark double question mark su
has to map on to some option some theme
option to information by making sense
this actually works now what works
evaluate that but you just wrote in the
previous version in this version in the
current version not there yeah right of
course it does because that's the same
thing as question mark P asterisk I
think we are converging on something
perfectly reasonable here we've got some
graphic design modification to make to
merge these two designs okay
then we've got a question mark turns
into information of the string following
the question mark which at least the
standalone kernel is what it already
does I mean while the other piece is
that these summary blobs have to come
out reasonably in the standalone kernel
there's a fair amount of you know nice
functionality associated with these
printed forms which they don't know how
nice lose it let's try to not lose it I
mean you know worst case the thing can
just say am I in a terminal if so do the
allow I'm not talking about terminals
right you can click on those symbols
right now right great click on yeah
right and so I mean actually did
something totally crazy here it just it
just destroyed my notebook that's weird
I've never there's a band if this is
yeah a twelve-hour prototype then
there's actually was a bug with with
cell locating
functions and just yeah there we go
right in this case the sense that it's
this is pretty cruddy why isn't that
generating the the why isn't that
showing them the usage messages this may
be a bug in my build which must must
must be fixed I'm sorry I see that
problem him in the last build I he
unrolled it so it's not only your bit of
story okay
Roger is reporting that documentation
layout is missing in builds 412 but
that's irrelevant to my 11:3 okay so it
seems like question mark already auto
stringify is its argument so right so I
mean we'd only be breaking people typing
in information and finding that it's no
longer hold all if we just say just all
right fine I think we've got a
resolution and I think we need a graphic
design meeting to go through how to
merge these looks and I think otherwise
this is resolved and very nice and now
we should just support information for
more and more kinds of objects and we
can get rid of things like classifier
information and so on yeah right I mean
I will just not write the other
signification means that the question
mark form can only ever work with
symbols and operators well I'm just
saying if people if people think that
information is the same thing as
question mark and they try to type in
and to you know question mark entity
Open bracket blah worried about that
let's not worry about that but I think I
think I personally favor in the future
the question mark at the beginning of a
line should do something more like equal
sign
okay that could go into something which
has for example all kinds of
autocompletes and all kinds of wild
things okay I can imagine for example a
fat you know I can imagine that in this
case it would be you know it would give
some kind of fat also complete there
already has documentation here because
it knows that you're in a documentation
all mode if you get what I'm saying
because right now you just type in code
but it knows that you're trying to look
for information about sign so it might
as well generate the one line you know
the one-line summary of sign right here
in the autocomplete but weather fear on
your way to cinch
a I'm suggesting it does it for all of
them right I see that it becomes a fat
autocomplete just like you know the the
the menu at the top of our website is
fat or like wolf alpha you know has fat
autocomplete they see actually I think
wolf mouth a fat autocomplete only
patents the top entry and so you have to
mouse down to see the fattening of the
lower entries which I think is fine
since autocomplete tries to sort by you
know the most frequent first alright I
think we've come to a great conclusion
here I think we are we can wrap up okay
okay but we will need a follow up design
sushma can you design meeting and you
know looks good well done alright thanks
to folks on the live stream some useful
suggestions much appreciated and thanks
to the people the live people as opposed
to lifestyle what but I don't know what
it's I would say in real life but that's
not right and I don't know what the heck
they've been the the non streamed people
face attacking people the the orally
talking people yes
that's right they bit the talking people
yeah okay voice Channel people that's a
good All Right see y'all soon thanks